Thanks Greg. Our emotion involves changes in the brain as well as the body.
There are particular brain regions that are involved in the experience and
expression of emotion. More than any other brain structure, the amygdala is
active in controlling emotional experience, especially fear. It's been shown
that people who have damage to the amygdala, don't actually show fear.
Relatedly, psychopaths, people who are cold and remorseless individuals, who
deceive and lie their way through life, often have an abnormally small
malfunctioning amygdala. In addition, some violent criminals have been show to
have tumors on their amygdala. The Amygdala is also involved in recognizing
fear in other people, based on their facial expressions, but not other
emotions. In addition, it's important to note, the left prefrontal cortex is
most active when experiencing positive emotions, such as joy or happiness.
However on the other hand, the right prefrontal cortex is most active when we
experience negative emotions, such as fear or sadness. And when we experience
pleasure, the hypothalamus is active.